[Musique]
avec
le silence d'un
je prierais
les bosquets sont
pleurer pendant l'après-midi et la rivière
grandi notre aventure est
[Musique]
murmurant Ay Ay Ay
Ouais, ouais, ouais
ouais pêcheur
pêcheur, j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait cet amour dans le
rivière, sortir du courant qui peut
mourir mourir de
froid oh oh oh oh
ouais
[Musique]
j'ai oublié de vous dire IL est des hles
canaries enfin écoutez écoutez vous vous
vous fatiguez de trop dans cette émission
vous vous vous travaillez beaucoup je
Vous constaterez que vous avez rendu la partie facile
et Moi Je veux faire la Part Plus
allez difficile
[Musique]
avec lui
silence d'une prière les bosquets
sont
pleurer pendant l'après-midi et la rivière
grandi notre aventure est
[Musique]
murmurant
ouais, ouais, ouais
ouais pêcheur
pêcheur, j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait cet amour dans le
rivière, sortir du courant qui peut
mourir mourir de
froid
[Musique]
ouais
Yo